s'il ya bien un mot que je kiffe c'est
le mot lors le lors comme le dit
wikipedia c'est l'histoire d'un univers
de fiction ne constituant pas l'intrigué
principale d'une oeuvre et moi c'est
quelque chose qui me passionne connaître
les secrets les origines les mystères
d'un univers nous avions déjà eu
l'occasion d'en parler dans un trois
théories dédié à zelda et puis bon même
si le mot l'or n'est pas dans chaque
titre de ce que je vous produit la
plupart des vidéos de la chaîne traite
d'extension d'un univers de la pop
culture
bref après zelda il est temps passé à
l'univers de pokémon que j'affectionne
beaucoup
bien que je sois un fan de la licence
j'ai conscience que ce ne soit pas le
sujet de prédilection de beaucoup de
monde sur la chaîne
c'est pourquoi ma mission va être de
réussir à vous faire découvrir les
profond mystère des jeux pokémon tout en
étant le plus accessible à tous bien
évidemment c'est une vidéo 100%
subjective et dont les théories m'ont
pris beaucoup de temps à imaginer ce ne
sont pas des vérités ou des réponses
mais simplement ma vision et mon
interprétation de l'univers bref allez
c'est parti
[Musique]
à
2007 c'est l'année d'arrivée des jeux
pokémon qui vont fait découvrir la
licence pokémon diamant et perle
outre le fait que ces jeux pokémon
suivre à la lettre les codes instauré
par les anciens jeux de la saga est
également qu'il fallait marquer
l'arrivée des premiers jeux pokémon sur
nintendo ds est bien la quatrième
génération se permet quand même quelques
petites folies avec de nouvelles
créatures bien loin des inspirations de
la première génération dans ses oeuvres
nous avons l'arrivée du trio de la
création respectivement représentées par
dialga le pokémon contrôlant le temps
palkia le régisseur de l'espace et
giratina le pokémon banni dans le monde
distorsion ce dernier et symbolisant
l'antimatière et là où c'est ultra
passionnant c'est que ces pokémon sont à
l'origine de la conception du monde et
de l'univers soit l'espace temps mais là
où je veux attirer votre attention et
quant aux pokémon qui a créé ce trio est
oui le créateur des créateurs argus on
dit que sont nos feuilles claude en le
niant qu'il est à l'origine de la
création du monde
[Musique]
arseus c'est la représentation du divin
quand on parle de l'univers de pokémon
soit d'une certaine manière l'équivalent
de dieu il est à l'origine de tous et a
donné naissance à 10 alga palkia
giratina bien jusqu'à maintenant vous
suivez dans la stratégie marketing de
game freak il existait des événements en
gros certains pokémons très rare et vous
vous doutez bien que dieu bas il est
rare et est distribué par la firme pour
justement attiser les ventes en plus de
proposer du nouveau contenu en général
ces événements étaient accompagnés d'un
petit bout de scénario qui permettait
d'accéder aux pokémon en question à
l'époque de diamant perle et platine la
version complémentaire des deux autres
jeux nous avions trois pokémon
accessible via ces événements qui
malheureusement ne l'ont été qu'au japon
si on ne compte pas mal affi et fionn
qui était accessible grâce au jeu
pokémon ranger via l'objet carte membre
vous pouviez obtenir bar crête sur l'île
nouvelle lune via la lettre de chaînes
vous pouviez obtenir chalemine au
paradis fleury et enfin le dernier
événement qui n'a jamais eu lieu
celui d'art c'est us dans la salle
originel par le biais de l'objet flûte
azur on y vient on y vient c'est là que
le mystère commence la flûte azur est un
artefact qui jouaient aux colonnes lance
permet aux joueurs d'atteindre la salle
originel lieu normalement hors
d'atteinte et où réside le dieu des
pokémon arceus une musique très étrange
se lance et un combat vous permettant de
l'attraper s'entame néanmoins c'est là
que ça a commencé à me gratter la tête
dans la description de l'objet il est
dit
une flûte produisant des sons qui
semblent provenir d'un autre monde ne
sait pas qui l'a fabriqué la mythologie
pokémon s'inspire d'énormément de mythe
et autres légendes qu'elle soit
historique fantastique religieuses etc
bref je vous avoue j'ai tout d'abord
pensé à la solution de facilité à z
ce personnage très décalé l'univers à
âgés de plus de 3000 ans ce dernier
était le roi de kahel hausse et a joué
un grand rôle dans la guerre pokémon je
me suis dit comment un personnage aussi
hors sujet a pu voir le jour dans la
saga personnes dans pokémon à plus de
3000 ans à part les pokémon légendaires
évidemment j'ai donc vu une punition
divine soi car qu'est us aurait puni à z
pour ses actions durant la guerre
pokémon en le faisant vivre en errance
éternellement vu que ce dernier a tué
beaucoup de monde par désir de vengeance
et puis bah pour aller encore plus loin
pourquoi la flûte azur de par sa couleur
ne serait ce pas directement une
référence à ce personnage au vu de son
nom à z soit qu'il a tout connu de a
jusqu'à z l'alpha et l'oméga
bref la flûte azur aurait pu être un
artefact de lui permettant d'entrer en
contact avec le dieu des pokémon mais je
pense que je fais fausse route
ce qui m'a intrigué en tout cas et que
la flûte azur même si on sait absolument
rien dessus et bien elle a la forme d'un
coeur humain
je me suis donc dit qu'en fait cette
flûte avait peut-être un rapport plus
métaphorique autre chose la question de
dieu et de la religion est un grand
mystère pour beaucoup
et chacun possède sa propre vision ce
concept de divinités justement très
personnel et pour moi la forme du coeur
humain en est sa représentation
puisqu'il est l'organe principal du
corps humain cependant cette flûte émane
un son qui proviendraient d'un autre
monde
la salle originel est comme une sorte de
dimension propre arceus quel gars
possède la sienne palkia aussi et même
giratina avec le monde distorsion
il se pourrait donc que sucker entre
guillemets soit un présent d'arqués us
lui
même un choeur signifiant la vie qu'il
aurait donné aux hommes puisqu'il est le
créateur avec un grand c un artefact
permettant à l'heureux propriétaire de
pouvoir voir de ses yeux l'être divin ou
du moins s'en approcher à moins qu'une
mission ou une quête soit derrière tout
ça effectivement vous êtes beaucoup à
espérer l'arrivée des remakes de diamant
et perle comme pour rubis oméga et
saphir alpha ou encore heart gold et
soul silver game freak va pouvoir
proposer un renouveau avec des nouvelles
features et background qui n'ont pas pu
développer à l'époque il est très fort à
parier que comme gros dons et kyogre une
sorte de prime aux résurgences soit
prévu pour des divinités tels que dialga
palkia ou giratina mais surtout un
scénario qui développerait les pokémon
très rare et qui n'ont jamais pu être
obtenue pour certains et là je vous
renvoie l'épisode delta avec des auc six
à la fin il est tout à fait possible
qu'au final nous aurons la possession de
la flûte azur et car caylus obtiendra
une sorte de forme originelle
étant donné que les films étaient plutôt
relié au jeu à ce moment précis il
serait incroyable que nous ayons pour
mission de réunir les plaques d'arqués
us pour lui rendre son véritable pouvoir
et sa véritable forme je m'emballe
peut-être mais le dieu des pokémon s'est
fait détrôner et il est temps qu'il
récupère sa place
[Musique]
s'il y a bien pokémon qui attire mon
attention depuis un long moment et qui
mérite bien plus d'attention
ce n est qu heureusement troisième
pokémon du trio astral de soleil et lune
nécrose mas est une créature qui aura
son jeu dédié par le biais les versions
ultra soleil et ultra lune ok mone dipri
smic
ce dernier peut absorber la lumière et
la réfractée ou également l'énergie de
soldats les eaux et luna là afin de
retrouver sa véritable forme celle que
l'on connaît sous le nom ultra nécrose
ma la lumière libéré par son corps
affecter la nature et les êtres vivants
de bien des manières
[Musique]
jusque là vous allez me dire tout est
normal mais creuse ma le troisième
pokémon dit légendaire entre guillemets
et il possède une autre forme beaucoup
plus puissante
un peu comme on nous présentait giratina
dans platine mais gare à quenza dans
rosa ou encore cure m qui peut fusionner
avec reshiram et zekrom voilà on y
retrouve une certaine cohérence et suite
logique
mais le truc c'est qu'en huit génération
de pokémon on n'a jamais eu une telle
créature ultra nécrose mas est le
pokémon le plus puissant tous jeux
confondus
placé devant arceus et mes gars et colza
ce dernier si puissant sous sa forme
originelle qui peut influer sur la vie
et l'environnement
et c'est ici que je m'interroge et
effectivement dans le développement
arceus est apparue en 2006 2007
nous sommes aujourd'hui en 2020 et les
jeux ont été plusieurs fois remanié
revisités comme nous l'a montré
rosa par exemple c'est pourquoi nous
avons un m'égarer cozza surpuissant
dépassant même arceus ce que je veux
dire c'est qu'il est fort probable que
le jour des remakes de la 4g arceus soit
revisitée avec probablement une forme
originelle du permettant de dépasser en
puissance ultra nécrose mas et donc
retrouver sa place de dieu légitime du
monde des pokémon néanmoins cela
n'enlève en rien la puissance d'ultra
nécrose mas et ses origines
notre monde est un monde sans lumière la
lumière a été volé par une créature que
nous connaissons sous le nom de nick
rose may et un jour elle viendra voler
la lumière d'al oula aussi comme une
éclipse qui nous passent jamais dans sa
conception ultra nécrose map possède des
capacités divine sous sa forme prix smic
il est une bête assoiffée de lumière
c'est pourquoi je pense que le préfixe
nécro lui a été attribuée nécro ramenant
à la mort né creusement à besoin de se
nourrir de lumière et d'énergie quitte à
ôter la vie
mais sous sa forme ultra ce dernier est
appelé ultra des creusements grand radio
soit un terme plutôt positif
quelqu'un de radieux est une personne
qui nous illumine de par sa joie ou sa
bonne humeur par exemple et c'est le cas
ici
ultra ni krausmann baigne le monde de sa
lumière dans cette forme au point qu'il
peut apporter la vie mais également la
reprendre s'ils le souhaitent je ne sais
pas vous mais pourquoi avoir construit
une nécrose ma de cette façon je veux
dire bien que mes gars est cozza soit
ultra puissant dépassant même arceus le
dieu des pokémon en terme de base
statistique barek wazza on sait qu'il
est le protecteur de la terre et c'est
tout il ne modifie pas la vie il ne la
crée pas non plus mais du coup au final
mais creusement ne serait-il pas
l'équivalent d'un dieu dans sa
conception
[Musique]
considéré comme le leader des ultras
chimères ultra nécrose ma semblent
provenir d'ailleurs de par son
étymologie nous avons vu que nécro
ramenait à la mort mais qu'en est il du
suffixe ozma il est fort à parier qu'il
s'agisse d'un rapprochement avec le
projet aux mâts ce projet des années
1960 consistait à capter des ondes radio
extraterrestres et je peux vous dire que
le symbole est très fort pour les jeux
pokémon étant une ultra chimères
c'est-à-dire un pokémon qui ne vient pas
du même monde
ce suffixe aux mâts on dit d'ailleurs
très long nécrose mas est donc ultra
nécrose ma ne proviennent pas de la
terre ou du moins celle que nous
connaissons il provient de l'ultra
dimensions et potentiellement de l'ultra
mégalopole plus précisément dans cette
ville où la lumière a été dérobé ultra
commando a abusé du pouvoir d'ultra
nécrose ma pour manipuler l'énergie et
la lumière afin d'alimenter leur ville
c'est comme ça que ce dernier a perdu sa
lumière que les cristaux z sont apparus
et est devenu une bête assoiffée
d'énergie voyageant à travers les
dimensions pour la retrouver
et bizarrement cela me rappelle
énormément le film dark et us est le
joyau de vie où l'humain souhaite abusé
d'un pouvoir divin qui ne lui appartient
pas
de par sa conception divine ses pouvoirs
et sa puissance ou encore le fait d'être
une ultra chimères ultra nécrose mas
pourrait être le dieu d'un autre monde
où d'une dimension parallèle inspiré de
la cosmologie soit de la recherche du
développement et de la création de
l'univers ultra nécrose mas pourrait
possiblement être leurs rivales d'arcus
un pokémon qui apporterait plus
d'explications scientifiques à l'univers
face à un autre avec une symbolique
beaucoup plus religieuse ce qui alimente
pour moi le mystère et que le pokémon
type-0 et son évolution silva liés sont
des pokémon artificielle qui ont pour
but de vaincre les ultras chimère au vu
de leur design
nous pourrions les considérer comme des
arcs et us artificielle des
reproductions de dieu créé par l'humain
ils ont pour but de combattre et vaincre
les pokémon de l'ultra dimensions dont
ultra nécrose m'a néanmoins c'est
probablement une réponse que
n'auront jamais à part c'est game freak
décide enfin d'expliquer comme il se
doit à leur univers nous resterons
toujours au stade de spéculation en 8
génération de pokémon ultra nécrose mas
est probablement le pokémon le plus
mystérieux
le monde de pokémon est très vaste et
son lors également
néanmoins tout cela reste très décousue
peu de réponses nous sont apportées à
chaque fois et ce malgré les nombreuses
portes ouvertes et nous avons exactement
le cas avec pokémon épées et boucliers
concernant ce qui entoure son histoire
ses mythes ou encore le pokédex qui se
découpe de façon particulière
effectivement c'est ce qui m'a mis la
puce à l'oreille et m'a fait partir sur
ce sujet sur les 400 pokémon qui nous
ont été proposés dans le jeu les
anciennes générations nous ramène
chacune 30 à 40 pokémon en moyenne à
l'exception de la cinquième qui quant à
elle nous aura même 85
alors que la huitième génération dont
les jeux et pmu clie sont dédiés nous en
amène 80 pourquoi ce choix
pourquoi autant de pokémon de la
cinquième génération et non pas des
autres c'est la raison qui a fait que
j'ai eu envie de creuser
l'une des grandes forces des jeux
pokémon sans le rapprochement entre ces
mêmes jeux nous en avons l'exemple avec
kaboul qui provient de la région de oen
qui seraient potentiellement le
grand-père d'adriano la championne feu
de ol ou encore la présence du troisième
type 0 recréer dans la région de galard
bref j'en viens à là où je souhaitais en
venir qu'en est-il de jean fleuret et
jean targe les descendants du véritable
héros de galard celui qui a combattu
laminoir aux côtés deux à sion et âmes à
santa eh bien j'aimerais faire un
rapprochement avec l'univers de noir et
blanc qui est également chargé
d'histoire déjà repensons au personnage
de getty ce qu'ils possèdent beaucoup de
similarités avec les deux frères
rien que dans son comportement sont
parlés getty sous emploi des grands mots
et se comporte comme une sorte de nobles
d'ailleurs la direction artistique se
rapproche beaucoup de ces derniers que
ce soit physiquement et même
capillairement les deux frères qui font
justement une très courte référence au
jeu noir et blanc rien de très
surprenant quand nous savons que game
freak font appel en général aux mêmes
travailleurs pour la plupart des jeux le
truc c'est que voilà il ya des mini
référence à tous les jeux donc les clins
d'oeil c'est compliqué de s'en servir
comme argument
bref nous savons que gay tice et n ont
pour nom de famille armonia
et si vous étiez curieux à l'époque nous
avons la présence des ruines des abysses
qui dévoilait justement qu'un grand roi
renier et ce n'est que théorique mais il
était probable que son nom de famille a
lui aussi était harmonia même si cela
n'a jamais été confirmée nous nous
doutons fortement que getty ce pot c'est
du sang royal et jean vient la légende
des deux frères et oui dans la
mythologie unis ça a été fondée par deux
frères jumeaux
voyant que les deux frères étaient bons
et se donner beaucoup de mal à réunir
les gens et faire le bien
un dragon est apparu pour accompagner
les deux frères c'était le dragon
originel cependant les deux frères
avaient des objectifs différents quant à
leur future 1 ayant une vision beaucoup
plus idéal et l'autre plus réaliste le
dragon ne sachant pas qui choisir se
divisera en deux et cela donna naissance
à reshiram et zekrom puis cure m est
apparu symbolisant la coquille vide du
ragon originel bref là n'est pas la
question mais dont le game design défini
par game freak et le fait qu'il lit très
souvent leur jeu il se pourrait qu'un
rapprochement soit a fait entre gallard
et unissent getty ce ressemble beaucoup
aux deux frères et ils pourraient tous
descendre chacun d'un frère précis en
fait il n'ya pas vraiment d'argument
incroyable mais juste des signes
étranges et nous avons l'exemple avec
des pokémon qui ne sont pas présents
dans le jeu dont énormément de
légendaires et chose que je ne comprends
pas c'est que ok ses légendaires
pourrait servir pour de prochains dlc
mais surtout outre la présence de j
rachis et celebi qui sont des fabuleux
et de mewtwo qui est aujourd'hui plus
iconiques autre chose nous avons la
présence des légendaires principaux de
la cinquième génération de la 7e
pourquoi seulement ses légendaires et
non dialga palkia giratina rayquaza
kyogre et caetera et surtout qu'il y ait
la présence des fusions de qmm avec
reshiram et zekrom donc la présence du
plateau un dn je veux dire pourquoi
instaurer 85 pokémon issus de noir et
blanc dans épée et bouclier dont les
légendaires de cette génération pourquoi
créer deux personnages ressemblant
physiquement et capillairement et
mentalement à getty ce tous en quête de
pouvoir et de couronnes eh bien
peut-être car game freak aimerait
approfondir sont l'or et son univ
mais tu n'as pas parler daz ancien roi
de callot c'est la théorie comme quoi il
serait l'un des deux frères jumeaux du
nice et bien il y a peut être également
un rapprochement à faire étant donné que
l'histoire et l'univers de pokémon est
très décousu il se peut que les régions
est à peu près tout le même passé dialga
et pâle qui ont beau être les légendes
de sinnoh le temps et l'espace ne
s'arrête pas qu'à une seule région
pareil pour groudon ekyog ils n'ont pas
façonné que au n etc
il se peut donc alors que les familles
royales soit issu de la même souche
un énorme merci à tous d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo et j'espère de tout coeur
qu'elle vous aura plu
je tiens également à remercier de tout
coeur goût plein de la chaîne trans qui
m'a prêté sa belle voix pour la vidéo
foncez voir cette chaîne le taf derrière
et juste immense est phénoménal bien
évidemment je vous le recommande aussi
mais bon je sais que vous le connaissez
tous ce bon vieux aeros f
n'hésitez pas à aller voir son contenu
merci encore à tous que le line up soit
avec vous abonnez vous lâcher un pouce
bleu et un petit commentaire
ciao
[Musique]